20-19 may seem like it's a long way off
but movie studios are already filling up
their slates with big-budget high-octane
adventures that theater goers are not
going to want to miss while some may say
it's a bit early for people to be
setting their calendar for midnight
release dates we say that you can never
plan too much ahead you might even get
some sweet much Star Wars fans braved
the cold long lines and traffic the
first 1,000 people got an exclusive
rogue 1 poster so poeple yeah popcorn
and clear space on the wall for all your
sweet you posters here are all the
movies that will blow you away in 2019
the lego movie sequel the first lego
movie was the surprise hit of 2014
making 469 million worldwide and
sporting a host of spin-offs including
the Lego Batman movie which made over
300 million worldwide in 2017 however
the actual sequel to the original film
has run into some production delays
pushing its release back to February
2019
one of the reasons for the holdup a
script rewrite from Bojack horseman
creator Raphael bob-waksberg now that we
can't wait to see how to Train Your
Dragon 3 check out the intense logline
for How to Train Your Dragon 3 as hiccup
fulfills his dream of creating a
peaceful dragon utopia toothless
discovery of an untamed elusive mate
draws the Night Fury away when danger
mounts at home and hiccups reign as
village chief is tested both dragon and
rider must make impossible decisions to
save their kind oscar-nominated writer
and director deemed wasps as the third
movie in the franchise set for release
in March 2019 will be the Hulman ation
of hiccups coming-of-age so expect the
movie to tie the whole franchise
together in one epic conclusion Captain
Marvel Marvel's first female led
superhero film pegged for March 2019 is
shaping up to be worth the way for one
thing Captain Marvel has Oscar winner
brie Larson as its lead an actress who
shown
has the ability to pull off action
comedy and drama and for another Marvel
enlisted the directing team of Anna
Boden and Brian Fleck who previously
helped cult hits Half Nelson and it's
kind of a funny story
add in the promise from Marvel head
honcho Kevin Feige that Captain Marvel
will be as powerful a character as we've
ever put in a movie and you have the
recipe for yet another winner from
Marvel Studios Godzilla king of monsters
another March release king of monsters
is the follow-up to the well-received
2014 Godzilla but that's where the
similarities apparently end other than
returning star Ken Watanabe the movie is
slated to bring in a whole new cast of
human characters with Vera Farmiga Kyle
Chandler and stranger things star Millie
Bobby Brown playing a family swept up in
the troubled the monster causes sorry
godzilla but we're betting on eleven
Shazaam it's been a long time in the
making but the long-awaited Shazam movie
from DC is currently slated to finally
hit theaters in April 2019
although Warner Brothers has yet to
announce a lead Shazam promises to bring
a new lighter tone to DC's otherwise
pretty grim film universe whether or not
Dwayne the rock Johnson will appear as
Black Adam remains to be seen as
Shazam's archenemy has already had his
own solo film greenlit either way it'll
be nice to see a DC film where at least
one scene takes place during daylight
hours
[Music]
fast and furious 9 Vin Diesel tased the
release date for the 9th and 10th films
in the Fast and the Furious franchise on
his Instagram before the fate of the
Furious even had its official name and
with the 8th movie tearing up the box
office in 2017 the 9th is sure to be
huge considering the fate of the Furious
purposely left some loose ends dangling
it seems as though this stage is already
being set to make Fast and Furious 9 the
fastest and most furious film yet if
that's it impossible for Avengers 4 in
may 20 19 the 4th Avengers film will
mark the end of Marvel's phase 3 which
means it's probably time to break out
your tissues with the first wave of
Marvel film franchises coming to an end
and with many of the big name actors
contracts expiring as well Avengers 4
will probably result in quite a few
character deaths for retirements we'll
learn a lot more about what to expect in
Avengers 4 when Avengers infinity war
hits theaters in 2018 but the movie is
sure to be a can't-miss adventure Star
Wars Episode nine Jurassic world's Colin
Trevorrow will take on directing duties
for the as-yet untitled final film in
the third Star Wars trilogy currently
slated for a May 2019 release and if the
past films have been any indication this
one is going to be epic 2017 s the last
Jedi should tell us a lot about the plot
of Star Wars Episode nine but we do know
that it'll provide a resolution to the
trilogy
according to Lucasfilm president
Kathleen Kennedy and if just the plot of
the movie isn't enough to get you out to
the theaters the studio is looking to
set up a future of standalone movies and
spin-offs meaning episode 9 will
probably be yet another launching pad
for years of the Star Wars franchise's
future may it never end to a story for
if you somehow didn't empty your tear
ducts forever during Toy Story 3 Toy
Story 4 will arrive in June 2019
according to Pixar chief creative
and Toy Story director John Lasseter the
treatment for the film was unbelievable
focusing on the love story between woody
and Bo Peep and showing Woody and Buzz
teaming up to find a missing bar the
movie also has big names behind it with
Lasseter set to co-direct alongside
inside out Ryder
Josh Cooley and a script by Celeste and
Jesse forever duo rashida Jones and will
McCormick I'm rashida Jones I'm will
McCormick and we are currently at Pixar
writing Toy Story for the big saw
Machine hasn't failed us yet and we're
excited to see their animated rom-com
on-screen
transformers 7 don't look now but this
yet another Transformers movie coming
out actually there's two as transformers
eight has already been announced - with
several more spin-offs and sequels in
development just what will happen in
June 2019 transformers 7 is a closely
guarded secret but we're going to give
you an exclusive right now it will
involve CGI robots punching each other
until your eyes and ears bleed motor oil
the only thing that could be better if
someone figured out how to combine the
franchise with Fast & Furious
so all those Autobots were being driven
by Vin Diesel and Ludacris hey we can
dream can't we The Secret Life of pets
to the original Secret Life of pets
flooded movie theaters with adorableness
in the summer of 2016
and although the sequel has been pushed
back to july 2019 from its originally
planned 2018 release date there are
still a lot of good things going for it
set to follow the continuing Adventures
of New York City's craziest pets the
sequel will bring back the writing and
directing team from the original that
means it should also be able to bring
back the magic that made the first film
so great
spider-man homecoming to Tom Hollands
spider-man is set to continue his
adventures in a second standalone film
in july 2019 it should follow another
year of Peter Parker's high school
experience similar to the annual
installments of Harry Potter
while we've already seen plenty of
spider-man films Holland's version
promises to be different in a number of
ways for one thing if what Holland says
is true about the sequel staying in high
school it will be the only spider-man
film iteration to remain there for more
than one movie that way it can my new
story ideas that other films have
breezed past there are lots of
possibilities for Holland's Peter Parker
and it should be interesting to see what
webs the filmmakers spin The Lion King
Disney's remake machine is already going
strong and Jon Favreau's live-action
version of The Lion King set to ascend
to the throne in july 2019 is expected
to be huge the movie will bring back
James Earl Jones to reprise his role as
Mufasa from the original with Donald
Glover providing the voice of Simba and
those stars already have some equally
impressive backup in the form of Seth
Rogen and Billy Eichner who will voice
Timon and Pumbaa given how well that
Rhodes live-action jungle book
adaptation turned out this is one you
won't want to miss
frozen to bundle up because frozen 2 is
coming your way in November 2019 not
much is known right now about the sequel
to the 2013 mega hit but we're ready to
guarantee it will feature at least a
couple catchy songs that are sure to
become karaoke mainstays for the rest of
eternity the sequel will further explore
the relationship between Idina Menzel's
Elsa and Kristen Bell's honor two of
Disney's most engaging and feminist
heroines today so while we don't know
anything specific about the plot yet we
can guarantee that frozen 2 is sure to
warm your cold heart
oh and also
[Applause]
hi
[Applause]
just when you finally got that out of
your head
sorry Masters of the Universe despite
losing Mick G as its director the
December 2019 Masters of the Universe
live-action film is still shaping up to
be a powerhouse thanks to the writing of
David s Goyer the guy behind Batman
Begins The Dark Knight blade and more
there are also a lot of a list actors
reportedly vying to play roles in the
film with more stars scrambling to sign
on to superhero movies in recent years
it looks like Masters of the Universe
should have no problem assembling an
impressive cast of characters track 5
track 5 won't hit theaters until nearly
nine years after shrek forever after but
DreamWorks is assuring viewers it will
be totally worth the way the fifth film
is apparently set to launch a reinvented
Shrek franchise with a whole potential
Shrek universe on the way as well
screenwriter Michael McCullough's said
there's been four movies and a lot of
materials so the characters are pretty
beloved and they're great characters but
you also have to think of a pretty new
take at that point well it's unclear
exactly what that reinvention will
entail it'll be pretty interesting to
see which fairy tale myths the franchise
decides to mine next the Batman right
now the big story around the Batman
comes from the movies numerous delays
but if you look past all the negative
talk the film is actually shaping up to
be pretty good Ben Affleck may not have
dissolved into the role of Bruce Wayne
as well as Christian Bale did but he's
been improving with every appearance
with the turn in Justice League coming
up he'll hopefully have more time to
settle into the character and to develop
his own caped crusader clover fields
Matt Reeves is also set to direct and
the script also reportedly recently
underwent a rewrite from an Oscar winner
with Argo and Justice League writer
Chris Terrio turning in a draft that
everyone is very happy with hopefully
they'll find a way to squeeze some of
this in
[Music]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all these cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]
[Applause]